this leads to Bitcoin right you're
famous for calling it the schmuck
insurance I'm not going to say that
we're in the situation where the
insurance is needed yet but we're
definitely headed that direction over a
long period of time
how are your views on Bitcoin kind of
changed over time and have you bought
more bitcoins sold Bitcoin or change
anything in kind of a portfolio
allocation standpoint so first of all I
think you said it exactly right which is
that I think that this is the set up
meaning I think Bitcoin needed a moment
like this for it to be relevant in 2003
oh sorry 2013 I bought a lot and at one
point I think I had almost 5% of all
bitcoins my basis is about 80 bucks a
coin I've never bought more most of my
Bitcoin now sit with a company and you
know they use it for trading purposes
they use it to run a bunch of other
strategies and I did that mostly for
safety and security and peace of mind I
didn't want to deal with it I wanted to
own equity in the business that equity
can be hedged that equity can be tax
structured advantageous ly and then it
allows them to run a big business which
generates cash and I can get a cash and
you know dividend stream so I have not
bought since I initially basically wrote
that article for Bloomberg in 2013 my
thoughts are the following right now I
think what you're seeing is that it's
still a speculative instrument and it's
too speculative for it to be reliable so
if you're going to make the case that
you know it should replace fiat currency
well one thing you have to look at is
the volatility of the US dollar and you
can't replace it with something that's 9
Sigma more volatile it doesn't work and
the reason it doesn't work is that it's
- again going back to what markets are
important the only market that's even
more important than the debt markets are
the currency markets and what you see is
enormous amounts of liquidity where 5%
moves so 500 basis point are newsworthy
well those 500
this point moves in the absence of some
massive exhaustion is that that takes
years to play out and in that there's
value because it allows more market
participants to be active in that market
so that they can use it as a critical
pillar of how they run their business
but now all of a sudden if you have
2,000 basis point moves a half-hour
you can't effectively use it and so what
it does is it pushes it into this ghetto
of day traders and and speculators and
right now that's where we are we're in
that ghetto and you need to get out and
the way that it gets out is that you
need to flush the speculators and day
traders out and you need to have still
some basis of interest from long-term
holders and then you need to have it
slowly look like the traditional
infrastructure could really implode so
again I go back to we are driving slowly
but we are driving towards a top of a
cliff and then we're going to drive much
much faster down that cliff tore down
that hill and at the end of it is a is a
huge brick wall the way we avoid it is
by pivoting to a resilient economy where
we introduced in efficiency and cost and
inflate our way out of it or debasement
the path dependence for Bitcoin is if it
looks like path two is likely it will
really emerge as a flight to safety and
over the next 10 years where this
trajectory is going to take shape and it
is a ten-year trajectory you'll have a
lot of time to vector into it to protect
yourself and to hedge yourself and I've
always thought of Bitcoin as a very
binary investment whether it goes from
80 to eight thousand to six thousand to
three thousand to thirteen thousand it
just it doesn't matter this is either
zero or it's millions because what it
will do is it will create a quasi gold
standard it'll create an index
except instead of having to own gold
where gold is owned by central banks it
is an instrument that has value that's
determined by in between its
participants and it's owned by everybody
so maybe the correct way to say this is
that it's not gold but in gold being
gold 2.0 which some people have used
about Bitcoin what it does is it
replaces the the method of value
transfer that you need for fiat money to
be valuable but that only happens if the
US dollar looks like it's going to
careen into this wall so I think that's
the bet so the setup is here so before
there was no path dependence meaning you
were speculating and not really hoping
because you know if you were if you're
using as schmuck insurance as I was you
were kind of hoping it would never come
in but now if the probability you know
was 1% that that it would be valuable
unfortunately the probability is now
probably like 5 or 10% and there's a
real chance by 2030 we don't find a way
to inflate our way out of this and that
the only way to break the back of
deflation is essentially to create some
quasi form of gold standard but it'll be
almost impossible to do that between
governments and central bank's they'll
never agree on an instrument and they'll
never agree on an exchange but then
bottoms up people could decide to do it